- I think most of your
audience can appreciate
that if you, as a
culture, had a monopoly
on the conversation for a
century, as progressives had,
and you start losing
control of that monopoly,
it is going to look
like chaos to you.
Your tension and fear
is going to be palpable,
and that tension and fear
is going to be contagious.
So some very, very bad
people are very, very worried
about losing their stature
and status in our society,
and that should make
right-thinking people
very, very happy.
(mysterious music)
- It's Locals week here
on the Rubin Report,
and I'm doing mini
interviews with creators
on why they decided to become
less reliant on big tech
and instead own their
content and community
and livelihood with locals.com.
Joining me today is the Willy
Wonka of politics himself.
Michael Malice, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks, Dave.
- I thought you were going to be
in one of your Michael
Malice get ups,
dressed as Tulsi Gabbard
or Bea Arthur or somebody,
but you're just giving
me regular Malice.
- Oh no, I'm dressed like
the little mermaid right now.
- From the bottom down.
- That's the mermaid part, yeah.
- That's the mermaid part.
All right, Malice, before we
get into why you're on Locals,
and you've had incredible
success there actually,
I thought I should probably
give you a little credit
because you've been
predicting the disintegration
of everything for quite some
time, and as a matter of fact,
you relish in it, but
also point to a way
that it will not
be all horrible,
and I think that's what
people are worried about.
Help me out with this.
- Yeah, I think most of
your audience can appreciate
that if you, as a
culture, had a monopoly
on the conversation for a
century, as progressives had,
and you start losing
control of that monopoly,
it is going to look
like chaos to you,
and your tension and fear
is going to be palpable,
and that tension and fear
is going to be contagious.
So some very, very bad
people are very, very worried
about losing their stature
and status in our society,
and that should make
right-thinking people
very, very happy.
This should be something
that's an opportunity for hope.
You know, you don't
tear down a building,
it's not like a snap of fingers
and then a new building's there.
It is going to have to be
that transition period,
which is going to be ugly.
This ugliness is kind
of like an emetic.
If you've ever had it
coming out both ends,
that's basically
what we're seeing.
The body politic is purging
itself of the poison.
- Yeah, what do you
think it looks like,
regardless of who wins?
Perhaps you want to
make a prediction.
In a year from now, when
we get to that other side,
the rebuild side, what do
you think that looks like?
- Well, the beauty
of chaos is you have
no way of knowing what
it's going to look like.
I think we all remember in
2016, after Trump got elected,
we were like, what
does this mean?
None of us had any clue
what a Donald Trump
presidency would look like.
On the one hand,
it could have been
like an Arnold Schwarzenegger
governorship of California,
where he's kind of
this middle of the road
lefty Republican, and
ends up destroying
the Republican party forever,
or he could have gone full
Giuliani plus law and order,
let's bring out the wood
chippers or the guillotines
or whatever, and it's
kind of been a mix.
A lot of it's much more
rhetorical than otherwise.
The other concern
is we don't know
what a Biden presidency
would look like.
There's two scenarios.
One is Biden is gonna
be a moderate Democrat.
Biden has been very
anti-crime in his career.
Biden is the one who
took down Bernie Sanders,
not President Trump.
Or Biden is gonna be
weak and ineffectual,
and Black Lives Matter
is basically gonna be
running the country
and Antifa's gonna be
running the country, and
the court's gonna be packed
and any kind of right wing gains
at a legal level
will be lost forever.
Both of these scenarios
are also plausible there.
We have no way of knowing.
All I know is that people
who are comfortable
are going to be
made uncomfortable,
and that, historically,
is a good thing.
- But either way, you want less
of these people in our lives.
Is that fair to say, Malice?
- Right, so when
they're running around
like chickens with
their heads cut off,
possibly, hopefully literally,
that is going to be good
because when they're
fighting each other
and they can't get
their stuff together,
that gives them less
of an opportunity
to try to inflict
their schemes on us.
And here's another
thing that should be
very, very exciting
for a lot of people.
Ron Paul, and then
President Trump,
have legitimized the
anti-war position
within the Republican party,
which had been the case before
with the rise of neocons,
and George. W. Bush especially,
became part and parcel
of Republicanism.
Imagine if Joe Biden,
without some sort
of enormous 9/11 event,
or even maybe with one,
God forbid, or President
Trump in a second term
said we're all going to war.
He would not have the ability
to form that coalition
that historically
past presidents have.
So to have that chaos
and that lack of ability
to form a consensus
is, in this case,
literally saving hundreds
of thousands of lives.
- Well, Malice, it's
that sort of insight.
That's why I love you.
That's why I quote
you all the time.
You've been an odd voice
of reason, somehow,
in these crazy times, and
your book is right over there,
right off camera right now.
Anyhoo, this is a good segue
to why you're on Locals,
because you were the
third person on there.
I hand selected you.
I said this guy will be perfect,
when we were just
sort of seeding it,
just to who could
be the test people.
Why did you think that
doing something off big tech
was gonna be good for you?
- It was such a no brainer.
I was looking for
an alternative.
I was on Patreon before,
and here are the advantages
I had with Locals.
I do not ever have to worry
that I'm going to make a video
or send out a tweet and
have everything I've created
vanished overnight.
I don't have to worry about
not having a recourse.
First of all, I could call
you, or you would call me
and be like, hey,
this is inappropriate.
Let's figure this out.
Number one, I have a call
in to the guy at the top.
Number two is ...
- For the record, I certainly
won't say that to you.
It's your site.
We're just giving you the tools.
What you do with those tools
is up to you, my friend.
- Do you want to play this fire,
because we can play
with this fire.
No, in all seriousness,
that was a huge advantage.
Second, the vibe of
Locals is this was a place
where me and people
who like what I do
and respect what
I do are welcome,
as opposed to being regarded
as something to put up with
and an embarrassment and
something to apologize about.
I don't think people
appreciate to what extent
the employees at,
let's suppose, Spotify,
are driven crazy that their
platform is being used
to further the views of
people that they regard
as literal Nazis, or
Twitter, or Facebook.
So when you have that
kind of disconnect
between the people
running the site
and the creators,
who are Jewish,
it's very reassuring to
know you're not gonna have
to sit down with
someone and explain,
no I would have been
against the holocaust,
and would have been a victim.
- Yeah, so part of
this, of course,
is that there's a pay wall.
You have a minimum, right,
but you let people come on
for whatever they want to pay.
I know some people must be
saying, but wait a minute,
Michael Malice wrote a book
called "The New Right".
He's an expert at what
the trolls are up to.
Why would he want
to be in a place
where there are no trolls,
because trolls won't pay you?
- All my followers are trolls.
I'm a professional troll.
I trolled Kamala Harris
very successfully.
I troll people all
the time on Twitter.
Trolling, at its best,
is the art of exploiting
someone's weaknesses and
turning them to former
for the sake of the
broader audience.
It is impish, it is
mischievous, it is fun,
it is very much Willy Wonka,
but it's not about
being hateful.
Me just telling you, hey
Dave, you're an SOB or that,
that's not trolling,
that's just being a jerk.
So I think people enjoy,
my followers certainly,
the people who support
me, enjoy how effective
puncturing these balloons
are of these pompous people
who have presumed to put
themselves in positions
of authority despite being
such mediocre people.
Here's one great example
I frequently use.
I'll just ask them, have you
ever considered the possibility
that you're the bad guys?
Just that one simple
question to the likes
of these operatives
really gets people excited
and gets some of them to
wonder, do you know what?
Maybe I don't have it
as much figured out
as I'd like to think I do.
- Yeah, do you think the
ship has totally sailed
with big tech, that
we're basically
just at the end of it now?
We all are on borrowed
time there, basically?
- No, but I think that any
time you have any industry,
it's going to at first ossify
into four to 10
major establishments.
It was the case in publishing.
It had six companies.
It's the case in music.
They had a certain
number of labels.
But after a certain
time, like in music,
like in self publishing
and the internet,
they might have a
disproportionate
amount of impact
on the market, but
they're not going to have
that monopoly control that
we're seeing to some extent now.
There's very few people
who are completely
driven off the internet.
The rest, they're
having issues with it.
The fact that you're creating
a competitive alternative
to them really is an
issue because just
if I'm not political,
if I could choose
between Patreon and Locals,
and they're both comparable
in their advantages, but
this has the disadvantage
that I might lose
my account overnight
for some political
reason, whereas here
that's not gonna be a concern,
and I'm gonna have a similar
ability to track audiences,
why wouldn't I go
to this other one?
- Have you booted anyone out
of your Locals community yet?
- I have not ever had to.
I've never had to warn anyone.
I mean having that velvet rope,
how I have it set
up is it's free.
If you want to watch,
read everything,
I have exclusive content.
It's five bucks a month
if you want to support me,
and then you can
participate and whatever.
We've had not even
any arguments.
The fact that I'm so big
on people establishing
their own boundaries
and being pro-joy
and not being so sneering,
I think self selects
for a certain quality
type of person.
- Yeah, do you find
it changes your mood
on a day to day basis?
I open Twitter, and
then a half hour later,
I'm like, ooh, what
did I just see?
It's like bathing in vomit.
Then I open up my
Locals, and I'm like,
oh, these are all good
interesting people
sharing things about
themselves, how pleasant.
- That is, for many,
for my community,
the Locals is being used as
an alternative to Facebook,
because when people
are posting things
about their personal
lives or someone at work,
the don't have to
worry about that,
people from high school,
casting dispersions them
or screen capping them, right?
For me, Twitter, and you and I
have different
Twitter experiences
because I'm much more
of a brawler on Twitter,
and I monetize the haters.
If someone comes at me,
I say it would be a shame
if people bought me this
book I don't really want
just to spite you, and
yesterday, I just made $100
to buy this antique book.
I think you and I have
very different experiences
on Twitter, and surprisingly
you get disproportionately
more hate than I do, and I
can't figure out why that is.
I'm not being sarcastic.
- I walked, Malice,
you know why.
Come on, they can't
let somebody walk.
- Yeah, yeah, right,
yeah, that's true.
Yeah, you're an apostate.
- It's religion.
You can't let the
non-believers walk away.
What's next for Michael Malice
in this career situation?
- My next book is
called "The White Pill".
I'm working on it now, and
this is really going to be
a manifesto that's gonna
make people very excited
and very hopeful about the
future of this country,
because we've beaten some
very bad people before,
and people don't realize
how bad it used to be.
- Are you surprised that
people don't realize
that we will get through this?
I mean this is sort of where
we started a few minutes ago.
A certain amount of
people just feel like, oh,
we've crossed some
Rubicon and now
it's just endless chaos forever.
They sort of don't
understand that these things
are cyclical, and that
it will get better.
- I think it's a
very useful technique
to tell your
opponents preemptively
that you can't win
and all hope is lost,
because then you have to
get a scratch in the battle.
This has very much been
a message coming out
from corporate media
that it's over,
give it up, you guys can't win.
We're raised to trust these
people, raised to believe them,
and some of us will trust
them and believe them.
Then it's like, oh, wait, no.
They've been lying to me about
everything since I was kid.
They're lying about this.
They want me to give up.
Here's the thing,
even if you lose,
at least you can lose
with your head held high.
To give up for the
sake of these people
and say you can't beat these
college professor types,
that you see these little
clips of them all the time,
to me is an absurdity.
- Everyone knows what
the red pill is, Malice.
What's the white pill?
- The white pill is
the possibility of hope
that the good guys will win.
- That's it, that's it.
- That's it.
- All right, pimp yourself out.
Pimp out your Locals.
- It's malice.locals.com, and
I'm glad to see you all there.
- You're a simple
man, Michael Malice.
I look forward to
seeing you next time
in full mermaid outfit.
Keep up the good
work, my friend.
- It will be a big splash.
Take care, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our
politics play list,
and if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety topics, watch
our full episode play list,
all right over here.
To get notified of
all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.